- However you wanna say, I'll accept.
- We're friends now,
but we're gonna be enemies
after this challenge.
Guys I'm here with Meghan Tonjes!
- Hi!
- We're doing the No Thumbs Challenge,
which was originally
created by Rachel Ballinger
here on YouTube.
I've tweeted out asking you
guys for everyday activities
that would be more difficult
to do if we didn't have thumbs.
- Correct.
- So Jack Ferry's gonna
read out a series of tweets.
We're gonna race to try
to get that challenge done
without our thumbs,
and the first person to get
to five will be the winner!
Meghan was saying before that
she plays guitar so she thinks she has
the strength and dexterity in her fingers
that's really gonna help her out,
and I don't.
- I'm hoping.
- I have long ET-like fingers
so maybe that will be
something advantageous.
- Or it'll be to your detriment,
'cause I got little fingers
so maybe I'll be able to like.
- Yeah.
- Hold it down easier.
(both laugh)
I'm doing this motion, and
I know it's gonna get GIFed
and it's gonna post to Tumblr.
- Jack Ferry, tape master extraordinaire,
- Everybody's favorite Jack.
This is the weirdest thing
a dude's ever done to me,
I will say that.
(Grace laughs)
- How many times Jack Ferry has now
since taped up my hands
here on Not Too Deep?
- Yeah.
- I think it's...
(tape ripping)
- It's like.
- Too many.
- Like it's way too many
than like friends should have
as a number between themselves.
- Can you move your thumbs?
- No.
- I can, but tape it more, tape me down.
(laughing)
- There we go, that one's in good.
- Turn into a crustacean.
- Grace are you--
- I'm great.
Okay, so Jack, first challenge.
- [Jack] Open a bottle.
- Open a bottle.
Oh no, oh no!
Oh no, fingers go!
- Wait, wait.
- No.
- Yeah!
- How?
- Do you want some help?
Ah yeah, feels good right?
- Yeah, that's a weirdly cathartic bet.
- [Jack] Peel a banana.
- Okay, easy, done.
How do you--
- I'm getting there, I'm getting there.
- Wait.
- [Jack] Oh Meghan.
- Meghan!
- This is getting GIFed too!
(all laughing)
- New challenge, can Meghan
make this not sexual?
As she slowly eat a banana with no thumbs,
which is a very weird visual.
(laughing)
Okay, two to zero, here we go.
Next challenge.
- [Jack] Open a bag of chips and eat one.
- Done.
- Aw dammit.
(Jack laughs)
- It's all about wanting it.
(all laughing)
- [Meghan] I'm like covered in banana
and Cheeto and water.
- Uh oh, this is intense build-up,
are we on American Idol?
- [Jack] Alright, you ready?
- Yeah.
- [Jack] Okay, write your
first name on a piece of paper.
- Okay.
No!
- Yeah!
- And your name is longer than mine!
Yeah that was actually pretty easy.
That one wasn't that difficult.
That looks great.
- Thank you.
- So three to one!
- [Jack] Cut through that piece of paper
with a pair of scissors.
- Oh I thought with the knife.
Oh with, cut through? How much through?
- All of it, all of it!
- [Jack] All the way.
(both shouting)
- [Jack] Oh, Meghan!
(Jack laughing)
- Thank you, thank you.
Show off how quickly you can get it done
and then help me out.
- Yeah, you're welcome.
- Ah, okay what is it, four to one?
Shit, okay.
Let's do this.
- [Jack] Make a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich.
- Done, done.
Okay, oh god.
(Jack laughing)
Oh yeah!
- Oh no.
- Does it have--
- How did you get that, oh
there we go, there we go.
- Does this have a cap?
(both talking indistinctly)
Done!
- No!
- [Jack] Ah, that's Grace.
- Mine's taste better though.
(Jack laughing)
'Cause mine's got love in it.
- I cut mine diagonally, legit.
Would two of you like this sandwich?
(Jack laughing)
- Yeah, that's great.
- Meghan Tonjes makes the
most unsexual challenge.
- [Jack] Floss.
- I mean, this is up for interpretation.
(Jack laughing)
- Knuckles are getting in the way.
- Oh my god, I don't even
know how to floss with thumbs.
- Ah yeah!
- Oh!
My dentist would be so proud of you.
(all laughing)
So not only was this a challenge video,
it's also a message about dental hygiene.
No more excuses, 'cause you
can do without your thumbs.
- This is still a thing
that exists though,
what is this?
- That's your takeaway.
Well Meghan Tonjes, thank
you so much for being here.
- Thank you.
- I hope that you enjoyed this challenge.
We're about to film, or record rather,
a full episode of Not Too Deep,
so make sure you go over
to SoundCloud or iTunes
and listen to that full episode,
and where can they find
you across the Internet?
- Meghan Tonjes on everything.
youtube.com/tonjes
- Tonjes!
I don't know.
- Got in a fight where
they were both yelling
about having guns.
(both laughing)
- Oh my god!
- He was like, "I have a (beep) gat."
And she was like, "I have a (beep) gat."
And I was like, "I'm gonna go inside."